haben maschinen ein bewusstsein das hier
ist das allererste video das ich jemals
auf doktor watson hochgeladen habe das
ist mittlerweile knapp fünf jahre her
und seitdem hat sich einiges getan
seit meinem allerersten video habe ich
knapp 100 weitere videos hochgeladen die
von euch über neun millionen mal
geklickt wurden
was aber wenn uns genau das jetzt zum
verhängnis wird
streaming erzeugt doppelt so viele
emissionen wie der internationale
flugverkehr
das ist kein scherz hebt das ist
tatsache das internet und vor allem
videostreams sollen den klimawandel
beschleunigen
und wer über autos oder flugzeuge
meckert der soll erst mal selber
aufhören netflix oder youtube zu gucken
und damit ist dieter nuhr nicht alleine
das hat auch der geschäftsführer des
hannoveraner flughafens gesagt streaming
soll das neue fliegen sein und sogar
doppelt so schädlich aber stimmt das
überhaupt
wir haben eigene forschungen angestellt
und auf den verbrauch dieses videos hier
berechnet um zu beantworten wie
umweltschädlich
[Musik]
christine maier
die schüler wollen dass die politik
eingreift das ist vielleicht die größte
gesellschaftliche aufgabe videos machen
knapp 60 prozent des weltweiten internet
traffics aus allein auf netflix werden
jeden tag 164 millionen filme und
serienfolgen gestreamt das sind ungefähr
500.000 terabyte jeden tag und alles was
du online macht kostet energie
eine e mail schreiben die neue staffel
haus des geldes gucken oder sogar auf
instagram scrollen diese daten müssen
also von ihrem speicherort zu dir
transportiert werden und genau diese
große datenmenge vor allem bei videos
soll umweltschädlich sein
das problem dabei ist die streaming
infrastruktur also rechenzentren und
netzwerke diese brauchen strom und je
nachdem woher dieser strom bezogen wird
wird dabei co2 ausgestoßen
netflix zum beispiel läuft über die
server von amazon web services also von
amazon
diese stehen größtenteils in virginia
und sind die weltweit größte ansammlung
von rechenzentren 2014 hat amazon
angekündigt in zukunft mehr server mit
nachhaltiger energie zu betreiben und in
den letzten jahren wurden dann auch 23
neue rechenzentren von amazon gebaut
greenpeace hat dann allerdings
herausgefunden wie es von erneuerbaren
energien keine spur
2009 10 wurden nur zwölf prozent der
amazon server in virginia mit grüner
energie betrieben
der rest wird mit fossilen brennstoffen
versorgt nachhaltig sieht anders aus
laut einer studie aus dem letzten jahr
soll streaming so für genauso viel co2
sich an spanien verantwortlich seien
doppelt so viele emissionen wie der
globale flugverkehr scheint also gar
nicht so unrealistisch ist aber trotzdem
falsch warum dazu kommen wir gleich da
allerdings auch dieses youtube-video
hier von einem rechenzentrum zu dir
gelangen muss bedeutet das dass
natürlich auch dieses video hier und
damit mein ganzer kanal nicht sauber
sind
okay aber von wie viel co2 reden welche
genau das haben wir uns mal genauer
angeschaut
das internet ist ein riesiges netzwerk
dass ganz viele kleinere netzwerke
miteinander verbindet wie du es werden
zwischen diesen netzwerken in kleineren
paketen verschickt das nennt sich packet
switching dieses video hier liegt zum
beispiel mit millionen von anderen
youtube-videos in einem rechenzentrum in
der realität liegt übrigens auf mehreren
rechenzentren überall auf der welt aber
das verkompliziert die sache an der
stelle etwas
deswegen lassen wir das einfach als eben
dieses video angeklickt hast hast du dem
server den befehl gegeben die dieses
video zu schicken um vom rechenzentrum
zu deinem dsl router zu gelangen braucht
es einen content delivery network das
könnt ihr euch wie eine autobahn für
daten vorstellen
bei der nun gut angekommen gelangt das
video dann auf dein smartphone auf dem
tablet oder eben auf deinen laptop damit
ich jetzt hier auf dem bildschirm
erscheinen
braucht es ressourcen das content
delivery network das rechenzentrum aber
auch der router bei dir zu hause
benötigen alle strom wie viel strom das
kommt auf die größe des videos an und
wie groß ein video letztendlich ist das
hängt wiederum von der piste ab um also
bestimmen zu können wie viel speicher
dieses video hier in anspruch nimmt
haben die diverse experimente angestellt
auf dem smartphone verbraucht ein
typisches doktor watson video circa
zwölf megabyte pro minute auf dem laptop
15 und auf dem fernseher sogar 20 auf
dem handy lädt ein sehr aufwendiges
video mit vielen schnitten 28 megawatt
pro minute herunter 43 auf dem laptop
und 37 auf dem fernseher
das liegt daran dass hier viele
bildinformationen in wenig zeit
übermittelt werden müssen um den
verbrauch dieses videos hier zu
ermitteln haben wir also mit einem etwas
auf wenigen doktor watson video
gerechnet das wären ungefähr 15 megabyte
pro minute bei einer länge von 13
minuten also 1 195 megabyte die vom
rechenzentrum zu dir nach hause auf den
smartphone gelangen wollen
ok wie viel strom wird dafür benötigt
youtube gehört zu google dabei das von
google leider keine angaben über den
stromverbrauch der eigenen rechenzentren
gibt mussten wir schätzen und mit
referenzwerten arbeiten forscher rechnen
zum beispiel bei rechenzentren mit einem
stromverbrauch von ungefähr 0,11
kilowattstunden pro terabyte im falle
eines verbreitungs netzwerks rechnet man
mit 0,1 kilowattstunden pro terabyte
wenn dieses video hier also dein
smartphone erreicht hat dann hat es
trommelwirbel bitter ganze 0,000 04 09 5
kilowattstunden verbraucht zum vergleich
den diesem handy akku hier steckt
ungefähr 300 mal so viel energie
sollte dieses video hier aber nicht nur
einen aufruf sondern vielleicht 50.000
aufrufe bekommen dann sind das schon
ganze zwei kilowattstunden
das sind immerhin schon 114 handy akkus
im zweifel verbrauch dieses video aber
sogar noch etwas mehr strom euer gerät
muss ja zum beispiel auch betrieben
werden
ihr müsst es zum beispiel nach einem
video wahrscheinlich wieder um zwei bis
zehn prozent aufladen je nachdem wie
stark die helligkeit ist et cetera pp
aber welche menge an co2 entspricht das
eigentlich leider kann man
kilowattstunden nicht so leicht in co2
emissionen einfach umrechnen
wie viel co2 ausgestoßen wird hängt
stark davon ab wie der benötigte strom
bezogen wird wenn ihr dieses video aus
deutschland österreich oder der schweiz
schaut dann kommt es wahrscheinlich von
dem google data centers in den
niederlanden belgien oder dänemark nach
eigenen angaben werden diese mit 100
prozent erneuerbare energie betrieben
doch erneuerbar ist ein sehr dehnbarer
begriff denn hier kommt es auf die
zertifizierung an da bestimmt auch noch
andere google rechenzentren auf der welt
benutzt werden gehen wir einfach mal von
dem durchschnittlichen mittel
europäischen strommix aus
dieser beinhaltet sowohl strom aus
erneuerbaren energien als auch strom aus
fossilen brennstoffen
hier handelt es sich natürlich auch nur
um hochrechnungen aber laut einer
statistik liegen wir bei 4 174 gramm co2
pro verbrauchter kilowattstunde ja groß
stößt in dieses video hier pro klick
0,01 gramm co2 aus bei 50.000 aufrufen
sind das immerhin schon 970 gramm co2
also fast ein kilogramm
das ist gar nicht mal so wenig
allerdings auch mit versuch hier jemand
bei einer autofahrt von 13 kilometern in
die luft stößt jetzt muss ich allerdings
noch etwas sagen ja das ist jetzt eine
zahl aber es ist super schwierig so
etwas zu berechnen wir haben hier sehr
viele annahmen gemacht und zum beispiel
gar nicht berechnet dass manche leute
meine videos gar nicht bis zum ende
schauen also auch gar nicht das ganze
video heruntergeladen wird
außerdem gucken bestimmt nicht alle in
4k oder auch nur full hd sondern
vielleicht sogar nun 360 ps oder 180 p
weil sonst die internetverbindung nicht
ausreicht ohne dass das video die ganze
zeit
und wie gesagt behauptet google alle
europäischen server mit erneuerbaren
energien zu betreiben weswegen diese
zahlen in der realität
höchstwahrscheinlich etwas niedriger
sind
aber natürlich haben wir auf diesen
kanal nicht nur ein video hochgeladen
deswegen haben uns mal die mühe gemacht
den gesamten co2 ausstoß aller doktor
watson videos zu berechnen
hierfür konnten wir natürlich nicht
einfach den verbrauch dieses videos mit
100 multiplizieren schließlich sind die
videos auf diesem kanal unterschiedlich
langen und werden unterschiedlich häufig
angeklickt zuerst mussten also ermitteln
wie lange ein video auf diesem kanal im
durchschnitt geschaut wird
dann mussten ermitteln auf welchem gerät
die meisten unserer videos angeschaut
werden und in welcher qualität
62 prozent von euch schauen meine videos
auf dem smartphone 20 prozent auf dem
computer 7 auf dem tablet 6,8 auf dem
fernseher und immerhin drei prozent auf
der spielekonsole also auf der
playstation oder xbox
liebe grüße erneut im durchschnitt
behalte ich eure aufmerksamkeit für fünf
minuten und 23 sekunden und seit beginn
dieses kanals wurden so knapp 95 jahre
lang meine videos geschaut ziemlich
krasse statistik wenn man sich das mal
vor augen geführt
ihr habt alle zusammen 95 jahre damit
verbracht mir zuzuhören dankeschön dafür
bei ungefähr 14 megawatt pro minute
wurden also für diesen kanal knapp 750
terabyte an daten verschickt und
empfangen
denn dabei benötigte strom müsste so
ganz grob 75 kilogramm co2 ausgestoßen
haben in den letzten viereinhalb fünf
jahren
das entspricht ziemlich genau einem hin-
und rückflug nach mallorca
also einem typischen urlaub im sommer
für eine person kann man do bin ich okay
mit tatsächlich ich habe schon immer
erwartet trotzdem haben unsere
untersuchungen natürlich fragen der
verantwortung bei uns aufgeworfen
ist dieses co2 meine schuld weil ich
diese videos hochgeladen habe oder ist
es eure schuld weil die auf die videos
drauf klickt falls ihr schlechtes
gewissen bekommen habt dann kann ich
euch beruhigen denn am interessantesten
an unseren ergebnissen war dass der co2
ausstoß dieses videos und generell auf
einem kanal viel viel geringer ist als
das was wir zu beginn gedacht haben
tatsächlich ist streaming nämlich gar
nichts umweltschädlich wie es noch bis
vor kurzem angenommen wurde
in den letzten zehn jahren hat sich die
last auf rechenzentren ungefähr
versechsfacht allein die
speicherkapazität von servern hat sich
vor 25 bis vor kurzer zeit seien
wissenschaftler davon ausgegangen dass
sich dieser anstieg auch auf den
stromverbrauch von rechenzentren und die
infrastruktur übertragen lässt klar wenn
mehr leistung gefordert wird dann
benötigt man auch mehr strom
mittlerweile stream wir schließlich in
4k live und auf zahllosen endgeräten
doch eine neue studie hat gezeigt dass
der stromverbrauch von rechenzentren
tatsächlich zurückgegangen ist
so verbrauchen rechenzentren im schnitt
knapp 25 prozent weniger als noch vor
zehn jahren
und das obwohl sich die datenmengen
vervielfacht haben das liegt zum
beispiel daran dass prozessoren
mittlerweile viel effizienter arbeiten
auch können wir inzwischen besser kühlen
und die abwärme der server besser nutzen
während also der anspruch an die server
gewachsen ist werden die daten
mittlerweile effizienter verarbeitet und
verschickt das bedeutet auch dass der
weltweite ausstoß von streaming nicht
ansatzweise so hoch ist wie der von ganz
spanien und somit auch nicht doppelt so
hoch wie der globale flugverkehr rechnen
wir mit aktuellen zahlen dann kommen
netflix auf knapp 0,018 mega tonnen co2
pro jahr
im vergleich der globale flugverkehr hat
2009/10 bei 915 mega tonnen co2 die
kinder werden kosten und rufen auf das
klima ich will netflix und dann wären
wir sagen streaming erzeugt doppelt so
viele emissionen wie der internationale
flugverkehr liegt muss aussage das
streamen doppelt so schädlich ist wie
fliegen ist also definitiv falsch
in erster linie ist diese aussage falsch
weil hier eine überholte studie zitiert
wurde
nur leider findet sich selbst in dieser
alten studie kein hinweis darauf dass
streaming doppelt so schlimm sein soll
wie fliegen selbst mit alten zahlen
stößt fliegen immer noch knapp doppelt
so viel co2 aus wie streaming also genau
umgekehrt entweder hat dieter nuhr also
bewusst zahlen falsch interpretiert und
für seine comedy show aus dem kontext
gerissen oder er hatte zu wenig zeit
sich diesen zwei seiten langen artikel
durchzulesen dem er hier selber zeigt
denn selbst dort wird richtig erklärt
das streaming nicht stoppen so schädlich
ist wie fliegen
natürlich kann man jetzt sagen dass es
sich um einen witz handelt und natürlich
kann man auch von komikern nicht
erwarten ein wissenschaftliches team zur
recherche einzusetzen
aber es gibt schon einen grund warum
gerade dieser teil seines länder
programms auf bestimmten fragwürdigen
seiten des internets besonders viel
anklang gefunden hat solche witze
funktionieren besonders gut in einer
zeit in der klimaschutz und unser
verhältnis zu selbst auferlegten oder
gesetzlichen verboten heißt diskutiert
wird
ärgerlich ist es nur wenn falsche
informationen benutzt werden um klima
proteste und klima aktivismus abzuwerten
und in ein falsches licht zu rücken
durch so überspitzte aussagen fühlt man
sich überfordert und das gefühl wächst
man könnte ihn nicht wirklich verändern
nachhaltigkeit und verzicht das sind
themen die für große kontroversen sorgen
das fahrrad anstelle des suvs vielleicht
mit dem zug in den urlaub fahren oder
auf fleisch verzichten
viele von euch leben und konsumieren
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon bewusst war
für andere ist es vielleicht nicht
möglich zu verzichten und noch weitere
haben eventuell auch einfach nicht die
zeit sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
und das ist auch okay nur durch so eine
darstellung wie von dieter nuhr wird das
gefühl vermittelt klimaschutz sei
übertrieben und aktivisten heuchlerisch
und darunter leidet der ruf und die
ernsthaftigkeit von klimaschutz
anstatt uns also untereinander für
einzelne aktivitäten ein schlechtes
gewissen zu machen sollten wir zusammen
leute nennt wichtigen positionen ein
schlechtes gewissen machen das
klimaziele immer weiter in die ferne
rücken
trotzdem gibt es natürlich maßnahmen die
du für eine nachhaltige und bessere
zukunft ergreifen kannst in erster linie
sollten wir uns alle darüber bewusst
werden dass das eigene verhalten und der
eigene konsum indirekten oder sogar
direkten einfluss auf unsere umwelt und
gesellschaften nimmt dann sollten wir
uns bewusst werden welche politiker man
auf lokalem nationalem oder europäischem
level unterstützen kann
die bereit sind sich gegen den
klimawandel einzusetzen und das sind
vielleicht jetzt schon die besten ersten
schritte die wir machen können
leute vielen dank fürs zuschauern zwar
ein etwas längeres video wir haben auch
schon sehr lange daran gearbeitet ich
glaube seit januar sitzt mir dran denn
es gibt wirklich extrem viele zahlen und
fakten die wir recherchieren mussten
sachen die wir ausrechnen mussten
experimente die wir gemacht haben
also lasst uns gerne den daumen nach
oben da wenn euch das video gefallen hat
und vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren und die glocke zu aktivieren
damit ihr immer mitbekommt wenn wir neue
videos hochladen
ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick
[Musik]